hey guys Joey here we have some amiibo
to unbox for you today as well as ledges
Elda breadth of the wild the switch and
Lin Gisella breadth of wild will be
coming out soon so if you want to
subscribe to our YouTube channel to see
more videos you can do that but for now
let's get to unboxing all right let's do
this big guy The Guardian right here I'm
just gonna rip it open no it's too
dangerous
this is the Guardian amiibo for
religious Elda breath of the wild
he is very large yeah yeah he is honest
and cool thing about this guy is that
he's very large but also all of his arms
you see are fully poseable too like
super strong yes you can alright next up
we have linked in his Archer outfit
right there with his bow and arrow
[Music]
so we have him on twisty tie here so we
got link this bow and arrow he is
incredibly detailed here you have all
the deep designs on his tunic and his
bow and also the arrow right there on
the back he has a shield it's all his
his quiver and a little cloud right
there which I'm assuming he's like
jumping in the air and shooting that off
the ameba stand itself actually has a
little symbol with a game right there
it's very pretty alright next up we have
Zelda here let's take a look we have del
D here not as much going on as link
right here but she did is holding a a
tablet which I'm sure is a important to
the game at some point here big swoosh
looks nice
do this guy Coughlin vocal a bad guy
right here couple Coughlin yeah alright
I want the bad guys in breath of the
wild that you seen him and many of them
in the trailers most likely little
almost naked goblin dude with a very big
club he's really ugly it's got a little
loincloth there next we have link in his
writer outfit which is him on his horse
and also oh good action going on there
[Music]
wow this one's actually very impressive
got the horse which is actually very
detailed as well and the rest of the
link as you saw earlier gear with his
shield this time though he's only a
sword right there oh yeah and he also
has a hood on and keep the design there
as well so we have the the smaller vivos
here for 15.99 and then the larger one
big Guardian fur $19.99 alright get
these guys out of the way box what we're
really here for box is somewhat smaller
than your regular DVDs or blu-ray cases
closer in size to the PS Vita so you
know they're really pushing the handheld
aspect of the switch
[Music]
yeah always like going around the mill
box right here
open it there is nothing other than the
cartridge and uh alternate box out right
there no instruction manual no paper
insert nothing all that can be found
online at nintendo.com I'm sure so the
alternate cover that's included in here
on the reverse side is link climbing
over a high rule probably a big mountain
actually let's slide that in the
opposite way back is just clouds
cartridge it's like even smaller it's
slightly thinner than an SD card switch
cartridge is about the size of an SD
card maybe a little bit narrower and a
little bit thicker in size but they're
extremely portable
and very lose about possibly alright
guys thanks for watching our unboxing I
got a run but we will have more switch
coverage and more videos of breath while
coming in the near future so stay tuned
for that
[Music]